we're in afghanistan months after the
taliban took control and the country is
facing staggering hardship with nearly
nine million people on the brink of
starvation and the economy on the edge
of collapse
[Music]
almost everyone you talk to has a tale
of suffering and we've been talking to
people from across the country who've
told us of being hungry of seeing their
rights being stripped away of having no
jobs and just doing whatever they can to
survive in the new afghanistan
[Music]
we start our journey here in the capital
kabul
we're being taken down afghanistan's
back streets
to avoid the taliban's many armed
checkpoints
escorting us is the leader of the most
unlikely and bravest of rebels
they've already moved once after taliban
fighters ordered them to shut down
because these rebels are girls and
they're in a banned art class and no
taliban threats will deter them not even
in midwinter with no heating
[Music]
every girl here knows the dangers they
face if they're discovered
but they've tasted education and they've
judged the risk is worth it
delicious
it's because we're drawing women whose
faces aren't covered who aren't wearing
proper hijabs their teacher explains and
the taliban believe that's a big sin in
islam
the young women saw their studies halted
when the taliban took control nearly six
months ago
in an instant their dreams crumbled
i wanted to study hard and i wanted to
become a good politician for my country
one teenager tells me
but she quickly breaks down at just 14
she already knows that ambition is
simply not an option for her right now
and that is heartbreaking
the taliban are increasingly intolerant
of women's protests about their rights
the latest was broken up by fighters
using pepper spray
[Music]
and they didn't stop there
we've spoken to multiple witnesses who
saw the taliban raiding several homes
including this one rounding up the
female organizers
the woman on the left armed raised
leading the chance has also been hunted
down
she's seen on the march holding a
picture of world leaders including boris
johnson accusing them of silence over
afghanistan our security do not approach
women specifically because this is an
afghan society we have a lot of respect
for women we do not threaten women ever
the taliban now run the prisons
the prison governor wants to show us how
well the taliban are running their
justice system
hey
salaam
alaykum the cells we're shown have
around 40 men jammed together
many have been here for months already
and they're accused of stealing adultery
not paying debts and fraud
the prison governor is behind us so they
answer our questions cautiously
but one with a fresh injury tells us
many are employees of the former
government
he says they've been put here without
proof or trials
the governor tells our interpreter not
to translate before we're moved on
the governor used to run a secret
taliban prison before they came to power
he and his men are implicated in the
disappearance of the female governor of
the women's prison
he says he's no idea where she is but
insists she was corrupt and she's
probably claimed asylum elsewhere
there's been a heavy media clampdown too
with unknown numbers of journalists
arrested and tortured hundreds of media
outlets have shut and those remaining
work under strict rules it means
unexplained disappearances are all
suppressed
i think it is
a dark future looking for us
yeah for the media
we are lost our jobs we all lost our
dreams
here in a small village on the edge of
the city of herat near the iranian
border these people have all sold their
kidneys to survive
the organ trade isn't new in afghanistan
but it's just got more desperate
every single person is hungry and
poverty is driving already poor people
to even more extreme measures
this man tells us we've no choice we've
already sold our kidneys now we've got
to sell our children
and they're suffering terribly the
taliban takeover meant a massive cut in
aid and these are people with few
options
we've taken efforts to conceal their
identities for their own safety it's a
highly conservative society but i'm
allowed into a room with the women
they agree to me filming their scars
some just a few months old the women
have sold their kidneys for less than
the men around fifteen hundred dollars
an organ
there's a lucrative trade with many
organs going to iran but the money's
still not enough
most of these women are still teenagers
with multiple babies but few rights and
now they're being forced to sell their
children so they all have a better
chance of survival
it is a tragic situation and one they
see no quick end to
there is a lot of women there who've
sold their kidneys are now thinking
of the last option which is selling
their children too
no one can tell me to sell my children
but we're struggling to keep them alive
she says and that's why we've thought of
selling them maybe better for them and
we get food for the others
we travel to the country's poorest
province badgis and the village of kala
is shark
this dire economic situation has also
meant many more young girls some only
babies or toddlers are being sold into
early marriage to other richer families
five years old
seven years
nine
six years old these are girls already
sold into marriage many too young to
even know their own ages
eight years they're often prompted by
their guardians
[Music]
six years the husbands they'll go to are
a decade or more older the last to talk
is five years old
the youngest in her father's arms is a
seven-month-old baby given in lieu of
medical bills
the girls have no say
there's not enough room in the tent for
all the parents who want to show us
their young daughters they've sold
we don't want to sell them she says but
we're poor and we have to eat that's
what we're told time and again and in
this remote village it was hard to find
anyone who hadn't sold their little
girls as payment in kind to settle debts
or just to buy food
some of the villagers are now living in
tents after an earthquake a few days
earlier which has reduced to rubble what
little they had
you can see
all the houses falling down all the
exterior walls have fallen down these
people were struggling before but nearly
six months after the taliban took
control the country's economy is
collapsing
and those like gulsha who thought life
couldn't get any harder are telling us
it can and just has
she sold her two-year-old girl satera
who she was still breastfeeding her
family was so desperate
with no food no water and lots of others
to feed she says what mother wants to
sell their children but there's no other
solution
they're cramming babies onto beds in the
province's main hospital in some wards
it's standing room only
she's already lost two other children
[Music]
youngest is only just clinging tomorrow
cadia has a range of complications all
of them normally treated easily but
these are not normal times in a country
where little is functioning normally
right now
[Music]
the baby has pneumonia measles a fever
and at the root of it all poverty and
little food
later the same night after filming this
cadillac
afghanistan's babies are dying at a
shockingly high rate
in the maternity wards samaya and the
other teenage mothers edged towards
labour filled with fear
like asiya she was sold into marriage at
14.
they're all living in a country with one
of the highest maternal mortality rates
every girl here knows surviving the
birthing experience will be one of their
toughest challenges
i'm really scared i'm going to die asia
says
you'll be okay dr tells her we'll look
after you
when 16 year old samaya is finally
trying to deliver her baby there's no
pain relief
there are few medicines at all here the
midwives must cut her if her baby's
going to be delivered alive
it's been a difficult and traumatic
delivery
and the baby is completely limp and
unresponsive
[Music]
[Music]
i'm really scared the exhausted new
mother says
she's worried for herself and her
newborn
she looks on as the midwives work fast
now
every second is going to count if this
baby is going to live
[Music]
he doesn't appear to be breathing
they frantically suck out the amniotic
fluid which is threatening to drown him
[Music]
they have few medical tools to help them
save this baby
but my goodness they're using them as
best they can
then
[Music]
they tie his umbilical cord
[Music]
but he's not yet out of danger and still
not responding well he's taken to the
resuscitation room where there's a
rolling queue of babies needing help
[Music]
they need to get more oxygen inside this
baby's lungs
[Music]
but the handcuff is defective
[Music]
most of these medics are working for
very little and have hardly been paid
since the taliban came to power and
foreign aid suddenly stopped
[Music]
but this little boy's battle to live is
their fight too both mother and baby
have somehow got through this but the
baby starts his life in a land where
most are hungry and the entire afghan
society is teetering on the edge of
collapse
afghanistan is a country which seems to
be heading towards a devastating
humanitarian catastrophe but those
people who are having to sell their body
parts and their children those who are
having to beg for food just to survive
each day those parents who are unable to
stop their babies from freezing to death
would all testify they're already in the
midst of a humanitarian crisis right now